aaron zavala is going to make his 13th
start for the indians savali off to a
really good start on his year eight wins
two losses 349 era the o2
struck him out looking curveball over
the outside corner
one down that was a slow teaser in a
really good location
bases are loaded and loaded for shed
long junior
ground ball to first bobby bradley has
it
and the flip to savali ends the inning
justin dunn on the mound getting ready
for his first start in 12 days
just off the il cesar hernandez will
leave things off and that's outside ball
four so the indians have their lead off
man aboard ahmed rosario
[Applause]
line drive base hit left field
cesar coming into the third he'll stop
there
and they're loaded up with nobody out
eddie rosario will be the batter right
field coming hard as bowers he won't get
there run will score and everybody moves
up 90. so eddie rosario puts the indians
on top one to nothing with his 34th run
batted in on the year and they're still
loaded still nobody out here's the pitch
a curveball that was in the other
batters box
on a 3-1 pitch
and bradley walks
and that'll give him his fourth rbi
nailer up now has an opportunity line
drive center field face it that'll get
ramirez home here comes eddie rosario
throw to the plate
gonna call him out
i don't think the hand ever got there he
ran into the catcher's leg and so that
is out number two it's three to nothing
cleveland and the right hand is o2 pitch
it is strike three called on the outside
corner and that will finally end the
inning a couple of strikeouts for done
but the indians get three
bottom of the second inning and bradley
zimmer to the plate
big bouncer
zimmer gets down the line quickly and he
almost beat it up but he's called out
i think they're going to challenge this
yeah they you know they can because he
got down the line and they're going to
say that zimmer put his foot on the pace
before the pitcher did and oh yeah oh
yes he did he beat it and it looks like
he beat it easily just from that replay
so this one
should not take long the headsets are
off that didn't take long
that's now first and third with one out
and now jose going to get another
opportunity line drive right field base
in that's going to bring home zimmer
rosario stops at second it's 4-0 in
cleveland as jose knocks on his 36th run
of the year bobby bradley leads off the
bottom of the third with the indians
leading seattle four to nothing
rocked deep right center field headed to
the bullpen goodbye
bobby bradley with his second home run
of the year makes it five nothing
cleveland well he got a good look at him
that first time up at home play because
he ended up drawing the walk with the
bases loaded
but he had a a nice pitch here that he
put a pretty swing on and it would stay
middle of the plate
and bradley deposits his first home home
run this year
right down the middle that'll be a
souvenir for one of the fans out there
and number two on the year so the blast
to right center and the indians now
leading it five to nothing
oh no
oh my goodness that was a direct hit
and austin hedges down in the heat
and i mean it's every player's
worst fear the fastball that you can't
get out of the way yeah
and that's exactly what it was justin
dunn visibly upset a number of the
mariners players
shaken about what they just saw but the
good news is
hedges alert
talking to trainer yeah
but hedges
looks to be okay and he is going to go
down to first base
a direct hit justin dunn is looking at
him from the mount as if to say
i am so sorry aaron zavali back to work
with a five-nothing lead facing his old
teammate jake bowers look at that nice
pit cutter outside corner carved
six k's for savali
11 in a row he is retired in the payoff
pitch
swing and a miss
another strikeout for savali number
seven is fan three in a row nothing
really fancy with this pitch just a
little movement
well that's all it takes though
[Applause]
in the air left field routine for eddie
rosario and the mariners go one two
three it's the top of the sixth aaron
savali has retired 13 in a row and
crawford takes strike three on the
outside corner eight strikeouts for
aaron somali
now the set now the o2 pitch
swing
and a miss there's a new season high
nine strikeouts for aaron somali here it
comes
swinging in the miss on a curve
he strikes out seeger and strikes out
the side and a career-high 10 strikeouts
for aaron savali
five nothing indians middle of ending
number six
bobby bradley he walked with the bases
loaded in the first
bradley trying to shoot one in the hole
what he does ahmed rosario flying around
third he'll score jose ramirez goes to
third and bobby bradley with his second
run batted into the night
boy that's pretty but bobby didn't try
to pull this pitch he stays on it
they're giving him they had three guys
to the right side
there you go my man get that two out rbi
harold ramirez open three tonight make
it seven harold ramirez drives home jose
and the indians lead is seven to nothing
now the route is on
a couple of two out base sits here in
this inning
seven nothing indians
swung out and miss he struck him out for
his 11th
k of the night
and that's 21 in a row
right back to savage
nicely
22 straight set down by the indians
right-hander blake parker is the new
indians pitcher
and a line drive left field eddie
rosario hasn't won down
seeger wraps it in the left is it high
enough it will stay up and it is caught
for route number two
high fly ball
left center field bradley zimmer going
back on it
book it
the indians take the series opener
behind dominant pitching
seven nothing is the final score
aaron sevalli goes to nine and two on
the year
as the indians are 33 and 27. seattle is
31 and 34.